should you upgrade to the new iphone 14  pro well the biggest banger was the new  display which has the new dynamic island  that actually makes the cutout a useful  part of the ui this shocked all of us  along with the always on display that  just dims down so you see the whole  thing including your wallpaper now as  far as cameras it finally ups to 48  megapixels that give you a lot more  detail and a new 2x mode along with much  improved low-light performance and the  third thing is safety with crash  detection and satellite connectivity  even if you don't have any service so if  you care about those things i do think  it's a worthy upgrade but for a lot of  people you might want to wait for the  iphone 15.